let's just imagine  that when we finish i'm going to let  each one of you pick out  the car of your choice  sounds good doesn't it  pick it out any color  you name it it'll be tied up with a bow  and it'll be at your house tomorrow  and you say well what's the catch  and the catch is  that it's the only car you're going to  get in your lifetime  now what are you going to do knowing  that that's the only car  you're ever going to have and you love  that car  you're going to take care of it like you  cannot believe  now what i'd like to suggest  you're not going to get only one car in  your lifetime  but you're gonna get one body and one  mind  and that's all you're gonna get  and that body and mind  feels terrific now  but it has to last you a lifetime